des pains et des viennoiseries au goût
du monde entier si les produits
fabriqués par aux germes sont alléchants
son chiffre d'affaires et guise aussi
les appétits
il dépassait les 100 millions d'euros
l'an dernier dont 63 à l'export et pour
se développer à l'international
l'entreprise a sa recette
c'est un travail de tous les jours c'est
un travail patient faut d'abord être
très fort sur son propre marché très
fort sur son propre marché faudra une
expertise faut avoir des envies et après
faut faire des rencontres or gmc des
rencontres l'histoire de cette société
c'est aussi celle d'une pmi qui a bien
grandi implanté aujourd'hui dans 16 pays
un exemple pour toutes les petites et
moyennes entreprises bourguignonnes qui
aimerait goûter à l'international mais
ne le font pas parce que c'est trop
compliqué on trop risqué qu'est ce qui
fait que les entreprises hésitent à
exporter mais je pense la peur de
l'inconnu
la peur de se lancer dans des marchés
qui ne connaissent pas qu'elles ne
connaissent pas ces entreprises et donc
nous sommes là avec notre nouveau
guichet unique pour leur garantir
justement les rassurer sur toutes ces
inconnues
ce guichet unique déjà en plaçant vaughn
franche comté c'est l'une des clés
proposés par le gouvernement qui donne
aujourd'hui aux régions un rôle central
dans le développement de l'export sur
leur territoire les régions deviennent
les copilotes on va dire un de la
recherche de développement à
l'international et c'est tant mieux
parce que la france est mal en matière
de l'export il faut aller encore plus
loin il faut développer nos entreprises
il ya dans notre pays cent vingt mille
entreprises qui exportent c'est très
très peu trop peu au 6600 entreprises de
la région seulement qui exportent
régulièrement parce que
la pluie